[Applaus]
hallo hallo walter krämer aber was
machst du da ich bereite mich vor
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ende das geht den bach runter geht
alles weltwirtschaft soziale
ungleichheit klimakatastrophe
naturkatastrophen kriege durch war
gerade im park angenehm sehr angenehm
schön waren
[Musik]
ich mache jetzt total total
ich hab hier vorräte für jahr der keller
voll alles ich kann hier nicht aus komm
mal her zu mir es gibt ja immer dass
mein bier und genieße es denn jetzt
kommt die show mit dem positiven denken
denkt positiv
[Musik]
hallo grüß dich
danke danke danke danke danke positiv es
wird gar nicht immer alles ein schlepper
dass ich wohl das blödeste was ich
jemals gehört habe ja rezession in zehn
millionen kurzarbeiter allein in diesem
frühjahr ja ich würde die größte
arbeitslosigkeit wird die dinosaurier
wird hat das alles wird über eine
billion euro
das geld das in beschlossen
das ist ein haufen schulden aber zeigt
auch was für ein verdammtes glück wir
haben hier zu leben ja jetzt haben wir
auch die chance mal grundsätzlich über
die verteilungsgerechtigkeit im
kapitalismus nachzudenken
gutverdiener könnten zb einen einmaligen
corona solid an jeder bezahlen
das bringt doch alles nichts
die reichen werden noch reicher und die
armen noch aber millionen menschen sucht
sich kaputt schuften sich einfach kaputt
im niedriglohn mieten explodieren jedes
fünfte kind wächst in armut auf gewinne
werden privatisiert verluste werden
sozialisiert die schere zwischen arm und
reich geht immer weiter auseinander und
für damen sind wir der nächsten
spielrunde die heißt der gini
koeffizient zeigt die ungleichheit beim
einkommen bedeutet alle haben das
gleiche einkommen 1 bedeutet eine hat
alles die anderen haben nichts verpasst
da liegt deutschland ziemlich gut es
gibt länder mit weniger unterschieden
zwischen arm und reich aber in den
meisten sind die einkommen viel
ungerechter verteilt als bei uns darauf
einen gin tonic hat sich in den letzten
20 jahren der haben teile extrem arme
menschen weltweit fast nicht verändert
oder c a deutlich mehr als halbiert
mein gott man die scheiß musikhaus
verdoppelt natürlich mehr als halbiert
immer mehr menschen geht das besser ja
tatsächlich eine weitere unglaubliche
tatsache hierbei gehen
positiv
gewalt und kriege nimmt zu nächste frage
werden krieg und gewalt mehr oder b
ich hab's kapiert es werden immer
weniger
aber auch soziale leuten in super jetzt
auch nichts
und recht hat er bei uns der bund da
kann sich die zahlen schön rechnen kann
ich kein bier mehr
viele dinge sind immer noch nicht gut
das stimmt
trotzdem ist das simple psychologie
reagieren alle viel stärker aus
schlechte nachrichten sind wenn die
fakten sagen dass alles
und damit sind wir auch warum zurück
positiv
jetzt habe ich jetzt liegt auch noch die
natur zurück was sagst du denn zu
katastrophen starkregen organe millionen
von klimaflüchtlingen wenn du das
positiv richten kann
kann ich mich klar der klimawandel ist
real aber wir können auch was dagegen
tun
auch eine chance nach oben zigmal
einschränken konsum reisen die autobahn
nicht wieder alles auf das alte niveau
hoch war
regionales bier trägt nicht hat diese
importierte hilfsappell finale quizfrage
hat sich die zahl der opfer von
naturkatastrophen in den vergangenen 100
jahren ja ja ja glück und hat sich
wahrscheinlich regiert das ist möchte
ich positiv bedingungen man kommt hier
auf die bühne zeigten sich mal das war's
dann doch leider schon herzlich lücken
und einer immer positiv bleiben wird
euch jetzt schlecht gut so
wisst ihr was ich noch schlechter
gefühlt die nächste folge zu verpassen
deswegen abonniert unseren kanal dann
kann sowas nicht passiert
[Musik]